- We're back with Daniel
Ranieri, Ben Affleck
and Tye Sheridan, y'all.
Their new movie is called, The Tender Bar.
The movie is about a
multi-generational family.
So we thought it'd be
fun to have them compare
some favorite things from
their own generations.
Is that cool?
We'll probably have more common than--
(laughing)
- You ever heard of the
car that crank, like this?
(laughing)
- You know what's so funny?
Is that they probably don't
remember like, rotary phones.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
- Oh, I remember rotary phones.
Yeah. I remember specifically
my grandfathers--
- You just said grandfather.
(laughing)
- I remember when he died
and we dug through his stuff.
- You were like, "What this is?"--
- It's like you gotta
understand what this is.
I thought it was the
coolest. You never seen that?
When you--
- I do, I know how to use it.
- Oh my God, I love it. See?
That's why this is important.
- You can run the computer real
easy, but the rotary phone.
- It will trip you up every time.
So wait, let's start with posters.
So what poster did each of you have
on your bedroom wall growing up?
I'll start here.
- I had at nine years old, at your age,
my favorite musician was
Prince, who is genius--
- [Kelly] Oh, very
sophisticated nine year old.
Oh my God, this is the poster?
- That is it.
(laughing)
I was nine years old. I
was a big prince fan that--
- Oh my God, what did your mom do?
- Well, my mom was very understanding.
I took the poster, I
put it up thinking like,
"Yeah, that's the guy.
That's the artist I like."
I remember her coming in and being like--
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- I watched like 15 different
thoughts go through her head
and she was like, "That's lovely."
- Like, "I'm okay with all of them. Okay."
- Whatever it was, it
was going to be okay.
And I was like, "Man, Prince is a genius."
- Oh my God, oh my God. So
what poster did you have, Tye?
- Oh man. I don't know
if I had any posters.
- [Kelly] You didn't?
- But I was, you know, if
we're talking about music,
I was into like, yeah, I
grew up in small town, Texas.
So I was into traditional
country, Marty Stuart,
George Jones, George Strait.
- Amen. Hallelujah.
- George Strait.
- Hallelujah.
- Can I get an amen?
- [Audience] Amen!
- [Ben] I like George Strait.
- I love George Strait.
- And he has a much more
number one records--
- Anybody. Yeah.
- That's incredible.
- Yeah. My aunt Becky
had a cardboard cutout
of George Strait in her house.
- In her house?
- In her house. It stood in the corner
and she had a sign that said,
"Thank God for George Strait."
(laughing)
- I think you've just explained
like every female in Texas.
- Yeah. Pretty much.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
Daniel, do you have anything in your room?
- I got a poster and George's
Batman. Not Batman whoa!
What am I saying? George from Ocean's 11.
(laughing)
- I have a picture of the best Batman.
- No no no. I have George in
Oceans 11, signed from him.
I got you as Batman signed. And--
(giggles)
- So you've like movie posters--
- And I also have Kobe Bryant.
- [Kelly] Oh that's amazing.
You like sports too.
That's amazing.
(clapping)
Okay. Since Tye mentioned
music, let's do music.
So Daniel, what kind of music do you like?
- I like rap music. I do.
I listen to this rapper who
passed away two years ago.
His name is Juice World.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah.
- And some of the songs I
like from him is Wishing Well,
Robbery and Lucid Dreams.
- [Kelly] Okay, awesome.
- Yeah. Very sophisticated--
- [Ben] Because his all
answers are planned out--
- [Kelly] I know. I'm like--
- I should've thought of something.
- What was your favorite music growing up?
Other than Prince, obviously.
- As a kid, you know,
I listened to a lot of,
I was dating myself, but I
listened to a lot of rap music.
Our neighborhood was very into rap music.
Yes, these were very
early days of rap music.
So it was like Grandmaster
Flash and The Message
and Kool Moe Dee and
Houdini and LL Cool J,
who I had the pleasure
of meeting recently.
He was a great guy. And so it
was a lot of like, The Message
every morning.
- All right, so is it true
that back in the eighties,
I have to ask you this, that
you were a break dancer?
(laughing)
Cause I heard that this was true.
- Well, show us some moves, Ben.
(cheering)
- [Kelly] He's calling you out.
(mumbling)
- Let me tell you something.
Matt Damon suggested
that he and I--
- [Kelly] He through him
under that bus so fast.
(laughing)
- [Daniel] Matt Damon.
- Matt Damon. We had some
nylon Puma suits, Nike suits
and those days, you
know, then the tracksuits
they were like nice though.
Then they were just one thin
like nylon sheet, you know?
But that was cool. And we
wore them and we, you know,
that was what was going on
and we wanted to be cool.
And so we learned how to break dance.
And then man, I was like,
"If we just get some of
linoleum and put it down
at the subway, we could do
some of our moves you know
and like put out a hat."
So it is not a lie to say that he and I
and a few other people who I won't name
because they have families
and some are in Boston now--
- You made money break dancing?
- Well, I won't say anybody
put quarters in the cup.
I think they walked by
with pity and astonishment.
"Oh, you don't see that much."
But yes, there's a lot
of popping and locking
and back spending.
And Matt tried to do the windmill,
which he never quite mastered.
I could get the back and the kick warm.
Although I never, if you
asked me to do that now,
you'd end up with a lawsuit
because I'd cripple
myself immediately, yes.
- Oh, that just love that.
I love, like, I wish
we had footage of that.
Cause like, knowing like, you know,
actors that we've loved forever,
like people that you look up
to, like in the limelight,
like seeing them as a young kid,
you don't picture them like,
"And they did this."
- Well, there are
certain people in my life
who danced for a living who
often like to make sport
of my dancing but I feel that I may, yeah.
I have my own spirit and my own energy.
- That means you can't dance.
(laughing)
That means you ain't got moves.